let's bring on Rabbi Taylor Rabbi Taylor
thank you for coming on the show thanks
so much for having me Michael so we we
started theology Thursday just a few
weeks ago we're cycling through
different religions religious traditions
and uh one topic that keeps coming up
though and maybe it's just because of
the age that we live in is
the occult demons we're the UFO stuff in
the air all this kind of stuff and I
always prided myself on knowing thinking
that I knew the Jewish view on things
because I grew up in New York virtually
all of my friends were Jewish I've been
to many of bar mitzvah I lived in Los
Angeles so I thought and then I was
talking to a Jewish friend of mine the
other day and she said Michael you know
how the Jews believe in reincarnation I
said wait what she said yeah yeah the
Jews believe in reincarnation I heard
this from a rabbi she said blah blah I
said wait she how the hell is there a
she Rabbi hold on wait what is this so I
realized I don't know anything about
Judaism and now I have your book a
Jewish Guide to the mysterious but even
better than that I've got you on here to
give me the answers directly so
do Jews believe in reincarnation why can
ladies be rabbis and then more
importantly to the topic at hand what's
all the UFO demon stuff
all right so um let's start with
reincarnation I guess so so one of the
big misnomers I think about Judaism is
we're called the people of the book
and it's interesting because really uh
the Hebrew Bible the way it was meant to
be given over generationally was orally
like the the Hebrew Bible is basically
like the the notes or the
um Cliff Notes I guess that a professor
would hand out an outline of the of the
lecture and then the the the college
professor gives the lecture and that's
if you didn't attend the lecture you
didn't hear the whole class you may have
a you know basic understanding of what
went on in the class but you don't
really um you don't really get the full
capacity of it so the the main body of
Jewish thoughts actually was carried on
orally using the Hebrew Bible obviously
as the as the as the index or as the uh
as the cliff notes but the discussion so
the the I what I'm trying to what I'm
trying to bring out is this idea that
some of the concepts in Judaism are not
very clearly written in the Revival even
the concept of natural life is not
really clearly written in the Hebrew
Bible uh reward and Punishment in the
Hebrew Bible is essentially if you do
what you're supposed to do you're going
to get the rain when you're supposed to
get it and if you don't do what you're
supposed to do you're not going to get
the rain when you're supposed to get it
there's there's not a whole lot of
spirituality and mysticism it's the the
Hebrew Bible talks directly clearly and
practically to people from all ages and
all time something that a farmer 3000
years ago could clearly relate to I
better do the right thing and something
where you know us in our in our modern
day we can relate to it in a different
sort of way in a different sort of level
um and and still gain and understand and
be motivated to do the right thing so as
far as reincarnation is concerned this
is something that the Jewish Mystics in
particular have have as has been a has
been a core of Jewish mystical theology
for for quite some time
um there's there are commentaries in the
Torah text that that discussed uh
various instances where you where you
would see reincarnation so for example
um after Cain and Abel have their Global
and Kane kills Abel the the the
what what the the words that the the
Hebrew Bible uses in the original Hebrew
is that when Seth is Born the who comes
that it says that he stood in Abel's
place and some of the Jewish Mystics
interpret that to mean that he was
actually sort of a reincarnation
fulfilling the mission that's Abel so
there there are there are places where
we see this in Jewish tradition I I
think I think a lot of people like to
focus on sort of the mysterious stuff
because living in a living practically
and living morally is a lot harder right
and so like I'd rather talk about angels
and demons and aliens and all this other
stuff because it's just fun to talk
about uh and it's and it's kind of just
theoretical uh and and so uh that's that
sort of that's a great point you know I
was reading in the nick of McKee in
ethics last night you know good old
Uncle Aristotle says that uh you know
it's fine to read about virtue but
virtue is is practical you know moral
virtue is a practical thing it's about
habit you just have to do it if you just
sit there and kind of muse about it and
read about it and banter back and forth
that's not going to get you where you
need to go you just need to actually do
the day in day out work of growing in
virtue which is a little less sexy but
uh you know ultimately more conducive to
your flourishing
that's our society though we like we
like going where it's just gonna keep my
mind entertained so right Angels demons
reincarnation lots of fun right so but
on that point you do you do write about
it in your book and the the my main
interest in it is not purely speculative
right now it's because this alien stuff
is taking over the psyop media sorry is
taking over the uh you know important
hearings at the U.S Congress and so I
think it's all a bunch of nonsense and I
think that either people are
hallucinating or they're seeing weapons
you know as has happened you know secret
weapons programs or I I do believe in
spiritual realities I believe in angels
and demons in spiritual combat uh so
maybe they're experiencing some of that
as the occult grows in our culture as a
traditional religious practice uh
disappears and uh
but also I think it's just kind of like
a psyop and a distraction so what is the
Jew do aliens exist you know is that is
that a possibility in the Jewish View
there's there's a possibility
um and it wouldn't impact our life in
the way that some people think that it
would so some people think oh my gosh if
there's intelligent life out there
that's the end of religion because
because oh my it's the the world the
world view that we had until now is is
completely is completely changed the one
of the one of the interesting things
that's discussed regarding Humanity in
the Jewish context is and it's this is
openly in the Hebrew Bible that
everything conceptually is centered
around the human being the human being
is seen as the sort of Pinnacle of
creation and and we're created in the
image of God and that's that's something
unique and in fact interestingly enough
in the in the Hebrew Bible texts
especially you really get the full the
full gist of it in the original Hebrew
that the difference between the way in
which everything in the universe is
created
compared to the human being is is subtle
but but vast the everything else in
creation the Bible describes it as being
spoken into existence God said let there
be light God said let there be plants
and animals when it comes to Human Being
Human Beings says formed from the dust
of the earth and God blows the Breath of
Life
and so the the Jewish the oral tradition
and the mystical text actually say that
there's there's a big difference between
speaking something into existing
speaking something into existence and
deep breath what's the difference when
you speak the air expenditure that comes
out is very superficial you can talk for
hours and you know and you know many of
us know people that can just talk for
hours
um and then but deep breath if you're
taking deep breath it's
you know you'll pass out after five
minutes and so the idea is that God has
a very a deeper relationship with the
human being than does with everything
else in creation and so the being
created in the image of God our
commentaries offer various uh ideas as
to what that actually means but the the
central idea as to being created in the
image of God means that you that we you
and I we have free will that we can make
moral decisions and this is something
that is unique to a human being the same
way that God can make it makes decisions
to for example create the universe and
completely uh undeterred by by anything
else a human being despite any
challenges nature or nurture can make a
free will decision to act uh just like
God in other words to not be influenced
by any sort of external factors so being
created in the image of God means from
from a Jewish Vantage Point means to be
a being with free will to be able to
make morals decisions that's something
that's unique to human beings even the
angels in our tradition don't have free
will demons don't have free will and
Aliens if they were out there they don't
have free will so in the same way that I
can conceptually believe in the idea of
angels and demons and that sort of thing
if aliens were out there if they were a
physical being from another planet and
they landed in Times Square tomorrow and
it was like universally clear that there
is life out there you know what I would
still do that morning I would still put
on my filling I would still pray because
okay I mean it'd be cool it'd be
interesting to to see and to to
reconsider things and kind of get a new
look at the universe but it's not going
to affect my daily because again one
thing I know about the about the the
aliens the angels and the demons is that
they don't have free will the human
being is created in the image of God now
does
is this Complicated by the account of
the fall of the demons you know the
Christian account is that there's a war
in heaven Satan Rebels uh and a third of
the Angels go with him and there's a big
war and you know it doesn't turn out
very well for Satan and then this is uh
depicted in later artistic Traditions
you think which I actually
coincidentally just referenced in the
show today uh you know you think of John
Milton Satan who says well I'd rather
reign in Hell than serve in heaven the
mind is its own place it can make a hell
of Heaven in heaven a hell does the
rebellion of
the Angels imply free will or does it
does that not factor into the Jewish
conception of demons
so it's it's interesting because one
thing I think that may be a distinction
uh in Judaism is that uh Satan or as we
call it in Hebrew uh is it means
adversary it's a it's a Hebrew word that
means the adversary uh we find it in the
Book of Numbers chapter 22 for example
where that word is used as meaning just
an adversary and there there is in our
tradition there is no sort of rebellion
in heaven that there was an angel that
had free will that said God I hate you
and you know I'm gonna go make a make a
big fight there's no there's no real
concept of like a duality that there's
the forces of good the forces of evil
and they're kind of duking it out and
then the good guys are going to win in
the end but what the the idea of the the
Satan or the Sun is is more sort of the
idea that it's an adversary it's
something to sort of bring you up in
fact one of the ways the Jewish Mystics
sort of described it
um is imagine you have a king who wants
to test the loyalty and the love that
his son the prince has for him and so
what he taught what he tells him is you
need to live a moral life you need to
make sure that you're not involved in
all in various forms of immorality and
you need to you need to be on the
straight and narrow and then after he
has a conversation with his son the
prince he goes and hires a harlot to try
to seduce the prince in other in other
words in other words the the harlot's
job is to entice the prince as much as
possible she her job is to is to really
try to get him to to fall right but the
Harlot knows that the whole the whole
thing is a game in other words the whole
reason that she's trying to entice him
is just to bring out the love if she
doesn't try to entice him then there's
no love and loyal be brought out but is
she not is the Harlot not culpable for
her even being used instrumentally to
bring out this love and to be this trial
is she not culpable I mean I think of
Judas right who Judas betrays Christ and
this is providential right Christ tells
you tells his Apostles one of you is
going to betray me Judas comes up he
says do you betray the son of man with a
kiss and go do what you're going to do
uh and he says you know the son of man
is going to be crucified but but woe to
that man who does it it would be better
for that man had he never been born
which is mysterious because you think
well hold on this had to happen this was
this is the the key of the story and yet
this person is still morally culpable
even for doing it is that
is that mystery worked out in the sort
of Jewish conception of Satan or even
like the temptress Harlot or is it or do
you get a pass if you're if you're doing
a bad action
for
a good end
so the thoughts on Satan is is an
emissary is is called the schlier an
emissary of God in for for the purposes
of challenging the human being bringing
out that love bringing out that loyalty
and that this the only way that that
Free Will can be expressed God God
wanted to create an environment a world
that seemingly is devoid of godliness
and that people should be able to look
Beyond the Veil that the world entices
us see The Godly core and make this
world into a place that openly reveals
godliness the only way that you can do
that is with Free Will and Temptation
and so the the Satan is an adversary but
uh the the focus and and also it's
important to note I think as well that
in Jewish tradition the satsun isn't
seen so much as the way it is in
cartoons with like the good little angel
on the right side and the and the the
devil on the on the other side
that the the focus of the challenge is
on what we call the eight serhara the
the evil inclination within all of us if
you see something that uh you desire on
the outside uh it's not so much the
thing that you're Desiring that's
causing you it's something on the inside
of you that's pulling you in that
direction right so this is this is
something that is the focus is on the
internal struggle between doing right
and wrong as opposed to some external
Force always kind of prodding Us in the
wrong direction right we'll have to have
you back and I'm very pleased that even
though you didn't give me the precise
answer I was hoping for in Aliens you
gave me at least most of the answer I
was hoping for which is who cares who
cares I don't care about the stupid
aliens uh which is pretty good and very
very interesting and you get the book a
Jewish Guide to the mysterious and uh
Rabbi Taylor we will certainly have to
have you back on the show thank you for
coming on it's a great pleasure thanks
so much Michael
[Music]